Jimmy sells his catch at the local
market he knows that he can sell only
fresh fish so he throws the bad ones
away regardless of the time it takes him
to find catch and clean the fish Jimmy
knows that if he were to sell spoiled
Goods his customers would not return so
instead of crying over stale fish he
considers them as sunk costs and sells
what customers actually want it is free
time Jimmy isn't that rational
unlike fish that don't go to the movies
Jimmy does he buys himself a ticket for
the afternoon show but it turns out that
a few hours before the film starts his
friends want to meet up to play football
Jimmy's favorite sport since he has
already spent money on the ticket he
declines the invitation according to
sunk cost's theory he shouldn't have the
money he spent on the ticket is already
gone and he won't get it back by
watching the movie what matters is that
he has a good time
Jimmy falls for the so-called sunk cost
fallacy the strong natural fear of
losing what we already own and the
tendency of our brain to treasure all
the things we possess
a more famous example of the fallacy is
the Concord the supersonic passenger
plane building the aircraft proved to be
very difficult and expensive but instead
of shutting down the project the British
and French government's continued
funding it even though they knew the
aircraft would not have any economic
benefit they argued that they had
invested too much to give up
[Music]
to test the sunk cost fallacy economists
Hal arcs and Catherine Bloomer came up
with an experiment using theater season
tickets the regular price for the season
was 15 but some people were randomly
given discounts of either Seven dollars
or two dollars it turned out that the
people who had paid the regular price
attended more plays than those who
received a discount
interestingly the only ones who behaved
rationally were children under the age
of six
behavioral economists suggest that there
are three psychological reasons for our
irrationality 1. loss aversion people
prefer avoiding losses to acquiring
equivalent gains most avoid bets where
they can win fifty dollars because they
could also lose fifty dollars
two the desire not to appear wasteful
this is why some finish their food even
when they feel full or don't think it's
particularly tasty
3. to ensure we do things we fear we
otherwise wouldn't we might buy an
expensive gym membership to make sure we
actually go and work out
assuming you are immune to the Concord
fallacy and you could completely ignore
all Investments you have ever made into
your education or getting to where you
are today what would you be doing
differently going forward can you
identify any sunk costs that are holding
you back from making those changes
[Music]
foreign
if you found this helpful check out our
other videos and subscribe if you want
to support our work join us on
patreon.com sprouts for more information
and additional content visit
sproutschools.com